This magical tale about the power of storytelling
and faith has so many messages that, like
The NeverEnding Story itself, are timeless.
Let's hop on Falkor and explore.
This is the ending of The NeverEnding Story,
finally explained.
The NeverEnding Story takes the tried and
true formula of the Hero's Journey and gives
it an interesting narrative twist by doubling
up on protagonists.
Atreyu is tasked with finding a cure for the
Childlike Empress, whose deathly illness threatens
the fabric of Fantasia while a dark force
called the Nothing eats everything in its
path.
From the Ivory Tower to the Swamps of Sadness,
the Southern Oracle, and the ends of Fantasia
itself, Atreyu searches for a cure at great
personal loss.
He loses his horse and best friend Artax,
which threatens the courage and resolve that
got him on this journey in the first place.
Fortunately, he makes a new friend in luck
dragon Falkor, who helps him get back on track.
At the first gate of the Southern Oracle,
Atreyu faces another test: this time he must
confront his own sense of self-worth, proving
he believes in himself.
He then has to confront the vision of his
true self in a mousy little boy named Bastian
who is reading a book far, far away.
Part of Atreyu's journey is complete when
he learns the Childlike Empress needs a new
name, and only a human child can bestow it,
but there are more setbacks in store.
Atreyu loses Falkor and his magical talisman,
and is forced to confront the Nothing's minion
with nothing but his own wits and strength.
Meanwhile, Bastian has his own part to play
in The NeverEnding Story.
At first, it seems like a simple framing sequence,
with Bastian reading a storybook about the
events unfolding for Atreyu and Fantasia.
He's grieving the loss of a mother who seemed
to support her son's sensitivity and daydreaming,
and his escape into flights of fancy are his
coping method.
When Atreyu loses Artax, Bastian weeps along
with him, because he has felt that loss himself.
"My horse died, I nearly drowned, I barely
got away from the nothing!"
As he reads, Bastian realizes that he might
be the most important hero of them all.
And to honor his cherished mother and her
memory, he even gives her name to the Childlike
Empress, saving her and Fantasia.
"Moon Child."
If it seems silly that a new name might save
someone's life, then you haven't considered
the power of what we call things.
Bastian is called terrible names by the school
bullies, which certainly affects how he feels
and sees himself.
With the arrival of the Nothing, the Childlike
Empress also loses an aspect of herself that
must be reinvented.
Her new name is a new start, not just for
the Empress, but for her whole world.
As Bastian makes his wishes, he ensures that
all the friendships made before the Nothing's
rampage remained intact.
He ultimately gets to experience a ride on
Falkor firsthand, and even gives his bullies
a taste of their own terrible medicine.
As the Nothing sweeps across Fantasia, a ragtag
bunch meets in the Howling Forest on their
way to the Ivory Tower: The Rock Biter, the
Night Hob and his Stupid Bat, as well as Teeny
Weeny and his Racing Snail.
They are all members of different Fantasian
groups with the same mission of beseeching
the Childlike Empress for help restoring their
lands.
This unlikely group quickly becomes friends
as they realize how each can help the others.
The Night Hob is able to fly to the top of
the Ivory Tower and hear the news.
The Rock Biter offers all the little ones
protection, and the Racing Snail is here to
shatter preconceived notions of what certain
kinds of creatures can do.
What bonds them is the shared loss of their
ancestral lands through the power of dark
forces, which brings a theme of colonization
into The NeverEnding Story's mix and leads
to a very grim moment when the Nothing snatches
the Rock Biter's friends right from under
him.
"They look like big, good, strong hands, don't
they?"
The Rock Biter gives up hope and allows the
Nothing to take him, but because of Bastian's
clever wishes, he and his comrades are eventually
reunited and continue their shared friendship
through the collective trauma they all survived.
One of the most satisfying things about a
fairy tale like The NeverEnding Story is how
far into destruction we travel before the
world is restored to rights.
The Nothing destroys all of Fantasia except
for a single grain of sand before Bastian
heals the Empress with her new name.
The forces of darkness are defeated, but there
is still work to do to properly restore all
that's been damaged.
Bastian has a huge job ahead of him now that
he's no longer just an armchair hero, and
when the Empress grants Bastian all the wishes
he needs to recreate Fantasia, it's a victory
against hopelessness.
When we see Fantasia rebuilt in a new form
of glory it reminds us that maintaining hope
in even the bleakest of circumstances is a
life-affirming act — and one we should strive
to cultivate as Bastian does.
Falkor might be the single most beloved character
in The NeverEnding Story.
Between his hearty chuckle and his friendly
canine features, Falkor is a reminder that
we must always fight against the kind of hopelessness
embodied by the Nothing.
While many times luck is actually a product
of good circumstances, timing, and privilege,
the luck symbolized by Falkor is about the
faith that goodness — and good people — will
ultimately prevail.
Even when Atreyu is convinced that he failed
to find the human child who could give the
Empress a new name, Falkor comforts him and
reminds him that he did his very best, and
that kind reminder is what draws viewers to
the luck dragon.
In a scene that has been traumatizing children
alike for decades, Atreyu loses his beloved
horse in the Swamps of Sadness.
Even today, people who have seen The NeverEnding
Story a hundred times know it as the most
brutal scene in the film, and some will even
leave the room to avoid shedding tears.
Looking at the big picture, though, the terrible
events in the Swamps of Sadness are a perfect
metaphor for grief, loss, and childhood trauma.
This is probably why adults still have a visceral
reaction to the incident even years later,
because we remember being Atreyu's age and
having to navigate our own losses in different
ways.
What ends up being beautiful about this painful
scene is how it shows us that even a warrior
isn't immune to grief.
For Bastian, the moment allows him to feel
his own grief, and begin to process the trauma
of losing his mother, and teaches him one
of the movie's lessons.
"It has to hurt if it's to heal."
Avoidance doesn't make wounds go away, and
pain has the power to remind us we are still
alive and healing.
Sometimes, people become more cynical as they
get older, and this can quickly turn into
bitterness and resentment.
It certainly does with Bastian's father, who
is all business and can't understand why his
son can't move on from his mother's death
as quickly.
He sees Bastian's sensitivity as weakness,
and so does the Nothing.
"Because people who have no hopes are easy
to control."
This is a scarily true statement in our own
human world, where every day, people lose
hope and turn to all kinds of ways not to
care about others.
Morla the Ancient one embodies this despair,
constantly saying that nothing matters, echoing
the apathy and cynicism that we often see
in adults.
Atreyu and Bastian, however, both refuse to
accept these supposedly grown-up truths.
One of The NeverEnding Story's most important
messages is having faith in the competence
of children.
Just because someone is young doesn't make
them incapable of great feats.
"He simply can't imagine one little boy could
be that important."
Sadly, Bastian has been bullied for the traits
that make him the ideal child to help save
Fantasia, so he has no idea how much power
he holds in his heart and imagination.
When he learns his own strength, though, it's
a lesson he'll hopefully never forget.
The NeverEnding Story is packed full of important
themes and messages, but one of the most fundamental
is about the dangers of bullying, including
the way that parents treat their children.
The bullying that Bastian deals with from
his classmates is awful and humiliating, but
the quiet bullying he endures from his father
is far more insidious than being tossed into
a dumpster by his classmates.
He berates his son for his keen imagination
and the way he expresses himself in ways that
are all healthy coping mechanisms for a child
grieving the recent loss of his mother.
This is one of the more painful aspects of
the film, and explains why Bastian wouldn't
want to come back to Earth so quickly once
he finally visits Fantasia.
Many kids who are sensitive and imaginative
find sanctuary in books and stories on their
best days.
On a bad day, however, like the one that sees
Bastian bullied by both his father and the
regular trio of tormentors at school, a book
is an even more valuable tool of escape.
He simply cannot deal with the real world,
and the only thing that makes sense to him
is digging into a book he's never read before.
There's an almost religious kind of sanctuary
in the way the film presents the act of reading,
and there's more to it than just escapism.
As the bookseller, Mr. Coreander, says, a
safe book allows you to return to yourself
unscathed by the end.
But a dangerous book will change you, and
fundamentally change how you see and experience
the world.
The NeverEnding Story also introduces young
audiences to the notion of metatextuality,
stories within stories.
"Just as he is sharing your adventures, others
are sharing his."
This narrative trick can draw readers and
viewers even deeper into a story by making
us a part of it, and that's a huge reason
why The NeverEnding Story still resonates
with audiences today.
As a film, The NeverEnding Story focuses on
adapting on the first half of Michael Ende's
beautiful book, about how a little boy saves
the world through reading.
The NeverEnding Story II: The Next Chapter
was released in 1990 with an entirely new
cast except for grouchy bookstore owner Carl
Conrad Coreander.
In this sequel, Bastian is trying to get over
his fear of heights, which he does not have
when he's riding on the back of a luck dragon.
When the Auryn, the mystical talisman carried
by Atreyu, calls to him, he returns to Fantasia
where a new evil, the Emptiness, is being
fueled by a sorceress.
She tricks Bastian into making wishes, all
the while stealing his memories of Earth and
home.
1994's The Neverending Story III diverges
completely from Ende's book and returns with
yet another new cast.
This time Bastian battles the Nasty, played
by Jack Black in one of his first major roles,
and reunites with many characters from the
original film.
When Atreyu reaches the boundaries of Fantasia,
he finds a temple in ruins with elaborate
paintings.
He's shocked to see the paintings are of him
and everything he survived.
The NeverEnding Story suggests that Atreyu's
journey, like the classic "Hero's Journey"
structure that it follows, has happened many
times before, and will probably happen again.
This cycle of life and destruction and life
emerging again is, in fact, a neverending
story, but more than that, the fight against
apathy and hopelessness and replacing them
with hope and faith is a story without an
ending, too.
Like the symbol of two snakes entwined eating
their own tails, these important themes from
the story continue to be relevant in the human
world.
The fact that after so many decades people
still watch, engage with, and adore The NeverEnding
Story is simply a testament to the everlasting
power of this triumphant tale.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.